I'm going to Fry's and he's got like his reading glasses on and I said,
hey nick,
what's up?
He'll call,
hey Joe,
I'm only,
I'm trying to get out of computer from my kid.
You know anything about these fucking things.
That's really good.
Hey Joe.
It was weird.
It's like I'm talking to Nick Noti.
Should I get a Mac that was only like 27?
No,
still confused.
I'm still like,
I can't believe I'm really talking to Nick Nolte.
This ended up right now with Nelson Real.
This is real.
We're at FRY's.
Hey Man,
nick needs electronics too.
That was during my,
my quake days when I was addicted to quake and I'd make my own computers.
You like you did all that shit.
But Dude,
you have like bill 15 screens and all that shit.
Like everyone does that.
Yeah.
I had a broom in my house where I had a,
uh,
like a conference table and it was lined up with computer monitors.
It computers.
I used to build computers.
Mac,
you don't play any games anymore.
While we're going to,
we just got,
when we set up these origin pcs we got a land room set up.
Local area network room.
Oh Shit.
All over the world fired up.
Well you know what man,
now that we have the studio there's so much room here and my kids come here and
play too.
You know there's plenty of stuff to do.
Yeah,
this is a lot.
Lots of so I'm just going to fuck it.
Put some games on for them but some games on for me.
Yeah that works.
I never got,
I never got into it for some reason video games I like I loved him when I was a
kid and then there was this weird cutoff and I was growing up now but so many
people still play.
Yeah,
the non grownups,
those,
those non growing up guys.
But I wish I could play like Jamie looking at him over there.
Take a big sweet kid.
Ultimate wear shirt.
It's like ultimate warrior shirt.
He's a fully grown man.
Chicks level to memorial dude.
They love guys who play video games too.
Right?
I had to sit inside all day.
Fuck yet.
Just button out too.
So I want to get pale more pale.
I want to Paler.
I want to be Paler,
Jamie.
The paler,
you know,
it scares the shit out of me though.
Those multi-role player,
what does it multi those giant role player you call them?
Yeah.
What of it?
What's the name?
Massively multi on.
Massive multiplayer online role playing.
Is that what Fortnite is?
No,
I sound like a fucking dad done.
Don't laugh at me shooter.
It's a third person.
You third question but isn't there but aren't you with a massive community of
people?
Yeah.
People.
That's fucking blows a hundred people in the game with you.
That's a lot,
dude.
Yeah.
Well that's a death match.
A quake death match.
A lot of times he'd mutton really a hundred but it can be a hundred a hundred
seems like it's absurd.
How many people are on your squat,
on your team up to four oh 50 on 50 match,
which is like a special,
is it random assignment to teams?
Are you going picking your team team or you can,
you actually can't go in random to,
you can do everything you want.
God,
I can't wait to hear the comments on this video,
but coaches do not know about fort night.
Dude,
I get so mad.
I have no idea.
I see so many references online to it and I know what it is,
but I have no idea what it is.
I remember when people would call you a newb and they'd use for OCM.
NEWB fucking newb
still goes on.
Does it still goes,
oh shit.
Like today there's like maybe even right now there's $2 million tournaments
going on.
There's one there.
I think they're both for charity today,
but one per fortnight and then another one,
another game that's just like a called pub g,
which we've talked about before.
2 million bucks.
Yeah.
How long do they have to play?
It might be like a two or three hour tournament.
That's fucking unreal.
So much money in video games now.
Parents used to tell their kids and not play video games,
like you don't don't be a loser.
And they still have that shit in their hand,
but it's,
there's more money in it then like most games people make careers out of it.
What if there were a tennis player?
Oh,
Bobby's a pro tennis player.
Bobby might blow his fucking ankles out.
Timmy over there is making $1 billion playing fort night and like you to do is
move his hands this all day.
I knew what college,
I know a guy,
a friend of my old roommate,
my first roommate in La.
He was like a PR professional online Gamer and I thought I was like,
what?
That dude fatality reached out to us.
Jonathan Wendell.
If they tell it,
I'm going to try to get them on.
I forgot it.
He's still playing.
He was the greatest quick player or one of the the,
it's hard to say.
It's hard to say the greatest,
cause there was a few of those guys.
He was one of them.
How old is he now?
He's probably in his late thirties something like that.
Yeah,
that sounds right.
What is he doing?
I always know what that,
I want to know what they do when they quit all that shit.
Just,
just breathe.
Just chilling,
trying to figure out how to deal with all the radiation they'd been absorbing.
He's working at FRY's.
Sit in front of that computer screen is,
hi Joe.
All your cells are mutated.
Well,
some of them now,
I think,
I think some of them are smart enough now that they realize the,
uh,
how quick the rises and how quick the fall might be.
That they're just sort of banking money and just riding it out to see how long
that goes.
Yeah.
But it's kind of like,
okay.
Kind of like how in golf you only get paid paid if you win.
Yeah.
Not a lot of these guys can bank all that money.
Right?
They still gotta have something to do after it's done.
It's the best of the best bank.
But the high majority of guys are just making a living.
I just said,
and this the way,
it's different though.
They don't have to pay a coach.
They don't,
they're just at home in their part.
In some cases their parent's house still.
Most cases I might just by their parents to new house.
That might be their goal.
They buy their parents house and kick them the fuck out.
Yeah.
That's happened.
By their parent's house.
The,
yeah.
You remember when you were out?
Like playing video games,
Mike,
get the fuck out and take care and with you pack our shit off to
Ryan's kicking us out.
Yeah.
Get the fuck out.
Uh,
you should have been so mean to him.
Yeah,
no,
the mom's bitching at him.
I didn't fucking know he could bought us this nice Tom.
Well,
toughen them up is why he became such a good player twice a fucking man.
When they're fucking assholes,
they take credit for it.
Toughened you up and that's why you liked this.
Yup.